- Did I hear that your mom
is living with you right now
to help you with the kids?
- Yes.
She actually retired and
became our full-time nanny
when my first, when my daughter was born,
about three and a half years ago.
She's been living with us ever since.
And honestly, she gets along
with my husband really well.
And who better than your
mother to look after your kids?
- Well, I was going to say that.
How's that going though?
Because I remember whenever
I was sleep training,
my eldest River, my mom and sister,
like, and I don't care yeah,
I'm saying it on television.
They totally shamed me
for letting her cry.
But the book said to let
her cry, if she's not sick,
you know, you got to let them self sooth.
And so I let him self sooth,
and I got hardcore shamed
while playing rummikub.
And I'm just saying like,
parents have different
ideas than what you have.
I feel like you might be siding
with my mom and my sister
on this one? (laughs)
- No, no shaming allowed.
And everybody does things differently.
It's like instinct kind of,
kind of what you say goes
because you're the one who had the kid.
- No, I know.
- Am I right?
- But do you not ever,
so your mom and you, you raised like,
y'all are doing it the same way?
Y'all never butt heads?
- No, no, no, no, no.
She, listen, it's such
an education because
I'm observing her parent.
Like she parented me with
my daughter and I'm like,
wait, wait, wait, you can't say that.
Let's not say that.
Can we, can we, can we maybe say it,
say it this way or
maybe not say it at all?
It's just, it's, she's a very
specific way of doing it.
It's in her bones.
She raised two kids and
I'm sort of new at it,
but I have a way of doing things
that I think is a little
gentler in some ways.
And when I bring it up, we
can compromise and we do,
we're very collaborative, but it is,
it is somewhat different.
I mean, I was a terrible child.
So that's also different.
My daughter is not.
- I think that's amazing though.
They get to grow up
around a grandma as well.
'Cause I didn't grow up with grandparents.
So that's amazing that they
get that right in the house.
Yeah.
- Also, they're getting,
they have three parents.
We have two kids and three
adults, three parents.
Who could be, I I'm,
I wish they knew how
lucky they were right now.
Really, I mean, I had
my grandparents close,
but yeah, it's different.
- Well, congrats on the birth of your son.
Don't you love having newborns?
I love the smell.
I want to eat them.
They're so cute.
- Yes, I leave the barn when
I'm working to go sniff him.
- I know!
- That's it!
- They smell so good.
But then they cry a lot sometimes.
- It's, the newborn phase is tough.
I don't, I'm not into it.
I've never, I wasn't
into it the first time.
I'm not into it now.
Yes, he smells good,
but I'm also terrified
to go to bed every night
because I'm afraid, he's just,
something bad's going to happen.
Knock on wood.
So yeah, no, I just I'm really
happy with three and a half.
If babies could be born
at three and a half,
that would be ideal.
- Like potty trained.
It's like, yeah.
If they could pop out potty
trained, I'd be into it.